techos por el piso y escombros marcan el
panorama de yagami la ciudad en el oeste
de Haití se vio sacudida por un nuevo
terremoto en la mañana de este martes el
epicentro del sismo se dio en el área
del cerroico en el extremo oeste del
país la ONU se mostró dispuesta a ayudar
a los damnificados
la ONU está lista para trabajar con las
autoridades haitianas y otros socios
para ayudar a aliviar el sufrimiento de
los necesitados en relación con el
terremoto y por supuesto del otro
desastre natural que son las
inundaciones y los derrumbes que se han
visto en los últimos días
los daños por el terremoto se dan en un
momento complejo para ti que ha sido
azotado por unas Fuertes lluvias durante
el fin de semana que dejaron decenas de
personas muertas perdió un niño por el
mal tiempo el río estaba desbordado como
usted lo puede ver Lo hemos perdido todo
estoy desnudo el Primer Ministro Ariel
Henry tiene que hacer algo
los habitantes de Leo Dan más al este
del país seguían sacando el agua y el
lodo de sus hogares el lunes según la
agencia de Protección Civil de Haití más
de 13.600 casas se inundaron Perdí todo
necesitamos un lugar para dormir pedimos
que alguien traiga ropa sábanas Porque
no tenemos nada
los estragos de los desastres naturales
se le suman al ya complejo panorama de
la isla azotada por constantes
enfrentamientos entre pandillas en marzo
la ONU mostraba que 530 personas habían
sido asesinadas en lo corrido del 2023 y
cerca de 280 secuestradas por estos
grupos